the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
today I want to get started by
correcting a mistake that I made last
time and this was a mistake in
terminology I said that that what we
were computing when we computed in this
candy bar example was energy and not
heat but it's it's both they're the same
thing and in fact energy heat and work
are all the same thing in in physics I
was foolishly considering the much more
what am I trying to say the intuitive
feeling of heat is just being the same
as temperature but in in in physics
usually heat is measured in calories and
energy can be in lots of things
maybe kilowatt hours or eggs these are
various of the units and work would be
in things like foot-pounds that is
lifting some weight some distance and
the amount of force you have to apply
and these are all have conversions
between them they're all the same
quantity in different units okay so
these are the same quantity different
units
all right so that's about as much
physics as will do for today and sorry
about that
now the example that I was going
starting to discuss last time and that
I'm going to carry out today was this
dartboard example we have a dartboard
which is some kind of target and we have
a person your little brother who's
standing over there and somebody is
throwing darts and the question is how
likely is he to be hit so I want to
describe to you how you how you we're
going to we're gonna make this problem
into a math problem yeah what topic is
this what we're going over we're going
over an example which is a dartboard
example and it has to do with
probability okay so what is the
probability
that this guy your little brother
gets hit by a dart now we have to put
some assumptions into this problem in
order to make it a math problem and that
I I'm really going to try to make them
pretty realistic assumptions alright so
the first assumption is that that the
number of hits is proportional to a
something like C to the C some constant
times e to the minus R squared all right
so that's actually a kind of a normal
distribution that's the that's the bell
curve but it's as a function of the
radius all right so this is the
assumption that I'm going to make in
this problem and a problem in
probability is a problem of the ratio of
the part to the whole so the part is
where this little guy is standing and
the whole is all the possible places
where the dart might hit which is maybe
the whole blackboard are extending
beyond depending on how good an aim you
think that this older child has so if
you like the part is is will start
simply I mean this is not this doesn't
sweep all the way around but we're going
to talk about some section like this
where this is some radius r1 and this
other radius is some longer radius r2
and the part that will first keep track
of is is everything around there that's
not very well centered but it's supposed
to be a two concentric circles all right
maybe I should fix that a bit so that
it's a little bit easier to read
so here we go so here I have radius r1
and here I have radius r2 and then the
region in between is is what we're going
to try to keep track of so I claim that
that will be able to get so this is what
I'm calling apart to start out with and
then we'll take a section of it to get
get the place where the person is
standing alright now I want to take a
side view of each of the minus R squared
the function that we're talking about
again that's the bell curve and it sort
of looks like this all right this is the
top value this is now the the R axis and
this is up or at least so so you should
think of this in terms of the fact that
the the horizontal here is the plane of
the dartboard and the vertical is
measuring how likely it is that there
will be darts piling up here so if they
were if they were balls tumbling down or
something else falling on many of them
would pile up here many fewer of them
would be piling up farther away and the
chunk that we're keeping track of is the
chunk between r1 and r2
that's the corresponding region here and
in order to calculate this part we have
to calculate this volume of revolution
sweeping around because really in
disguise this is a this is a ring this
is a side view it's really a ring
because we've been we're rotating it
around this axis here alright so we're
trying to figure out what the total
volume of that ring is and that's going
to be our waiting our likelihood for
whether the hits are occurring in this
section or in this this ring versus the
rest
to set this up I remind you we're gonna
use the method of shells that's really
the only one that's going to work here
and we want to integrate between r1 and
r2 and the range here is that because
this is I mean this is if you like a
solid of revolution so the variable R is
the same as what we used to call X and
it's ranging between r1 and r2 and then
we're sweeping it around and the
circumference of a little piece so it if
at a fixed distance R here the
circumference is going to be 2 PI R so 2
pi R is the circumference and then the
height is the height of that green stem
there that's e to the minus R squared
and then we're multiplying by the
thickness which is d R alright so the
thickness of the green is d R the height
of this little green guy is e to the
minus R squared and the circumference is
2 pi times the radius when we sweep the
circle around question
so the question is why is that what
we're interested in not the this pink
area and the reason is an interpretation
of what I meant by this what I meant by
this is that if you wanted to add up
what the likelihood is that this thing
will be here versus here I want it to be
really the proportions are the number of
hits times the if you like I wanted it D
area that's really what I meant here the
number of hits in in a little chunk in a
little chunk so a little maybe I'll call
it Delta a a little Chuck is
proportional to the chunk times that so
there's already an area factor and
there's a height so there are a total of
three dimensions involved there's the
area and then this height all right so
it's a matter of the what I had I mean
it was what I was given what I what I
intended to say the problem is yeah
another question yeah yeah exactly
the height is C times that whatever this
C is in fact we don't know what the C is
but because we're going to have a part
in a whole will divide the C will always
cancel so I'm throwing the C out I don't
know what it isn't in it and in the end
it won't matter all right that that's
very important question yes
to say saying number of his so what I
mean is the number of hits in some chunk
that is suppose you imagine so you know
the question is what does this left-hand
side mean is that right is that the
question that you're asking when I when
I try to understand what the
distribution of dartboard hits is I
should imagine my dartboard and very
often there will be a whole bunch of
holes in some places and fewer holes
else I'm trying to figure out what the
hole distribution of of those marks is
and so some places will have more hits
on them and some places will have fewer
hits on them and so what I want to
measure is on average the number of hits
so this would really be some this
constant of proportionality is ambiguous
because it depends on how many times you
try if you throw a thousand times it'll
be much more densely packed and if you
have only a hundred times it'll be fewer
all right so that that's that's where
this this constant comes in but given
that you have a certain number of times
that you tried say a thousand times
there will be a whole bunch more piled
in the middle and fewer and fewer is you
get farther away assuming that the
person's aim is reasonable all right so
that's that's what we're saying so we're
thinking I mean in terms of the person
is always aiming for the center so it's
most likely that the person will hit the
center but on the other hand it's a
fallible person so the person may miss
and so it's less and less likely as you
go farther out and we're just counting
how many times this gets hit how many
times this and so on in proportion to
the area
yeah r1 and r2 are arbitrary we're gonna
make this calculation in general we're
gonna calculate what the likelihood is
that we hit any any any possible band
and I want to leave those as just
letters for now the r1 and the r2
because I want to be able to try various
different possibilities again what do we
why do we have to take volume so this is
what we were addressing before it's a
volume because it's it's number of hits
per unit area so there's a height that
is number of hits and then there's an
area and that product of those is so
this is if you like a histogram of the
number of hits and this is but this
should be measured per area not not not
per length of R because on the real
diagram it's going all the way around
there's a lot more area to this red band
than just the distance implies okay so
having discussed that that's the setup
this is a pretty standard setup oh one
more question yes
yeah so the question is why is this a
realistic why is this choice of function
here e to the minus R squared a
realistic choice of function for the
darts so I can I can answer this with an
analogy when people were asking
themselves where the v2 rockets from
Germany hit London they used this model
it turned out to be the one which was
the most accurate so that gives you an
idea that this is actually real the
question this makes it look like people
are masters that is that they'll all hit
in the center more often than elsewhere
but that's actually somewhat deceptive
that's the there's the difference
between the the mode that is the most
likely spot and what happens on average
so in other words the single most likely
spot is the center but there's rather
little area in here and in fact the
likelihood of hitting that is some
little tiny bit in here in fact you're
much more likely to be out here so if
you take the total of the volume you'll
see that much of the volume is
contributed from out here and in fact
the person hits rather rarely near the
center so this and this is not a not a
ridiculous thing to do if you think of
it in terms of somebody's aiming at the
center but there's some random thing
which is throwing the person off then
it's there is likely to be to the left
us to the right or they might even get
lucky and all those errors cancel
themselves and they have fun to hit
pretty much near the center all right
yeah another question
how does the little brother come into
play the little brother is going to come
into play as follows I'll tell you in
advance so the thing is the little
brother was not so stupid as to stand in
front of the target
I know he stood about twice the radius
of the target away and so we're going to
approximate the location by some some
sector here which is going to be some
chunk of one of these things we'll just
break off a piece of it and that's how
we're going to capture so that the point
is the target is here but there is the
possibility that the that the
seven-year-old who's throwing the darts
actually missed the target that actually
happens a lot so yeah does that answer
your question okay
all right are we are we ready now to do
this one more question yeah I'm giving
you this property here I'm telling you
that this is what's called a a
mathematical model when you when you
give somebody something like this in
fact that requires further justification
it's an interesting issue people people
yeah I'm giving it to you for now and
it's something which really has to be
justified in certain circumstances it is
justified but okay all right so anyway
here's our part all right this is going
to be our chunk for now that we're going
to estimate the importance the relative
importance of and now this is something
this is something whose antiderivative
we can just do by substitution or by
guessing it's just minus pi e to the
minus R squared if you differentiate
that you get a minus 2r which cancels
the minus sign here so you get 2 pi R e
to the minus R squared so that's the
antiderivative
and we're evaluating it at r1 and r2 so
with the minus sign that's going to get
reversed the answer is going to be pi
times e to the minus r1 squared that's
the bottom one minus e to the minus r2
squared that's the top one so this is
what our part gives us and more
technically if you wanted to multiply
through by C it would be C times this
now I'll say that in just a second okay
now I want to work so if you like the
part is equal to maybe even I'll call it
C PI times each of the minus r1 squared
minus each of the minus r2 squared
alright that's what it really is if I
put in this factor so now there's no
prejudice as to how many attempts we
made whether it was a thousand attempts
or a million attempts at the target now
the the most important second feature
here of these kinds of modeling problems
is there is always some kind of
idealization and the next thing that I
want to discuss with you is is the
interpretation of the whole that is
what's what's the family of all
possibilities and in this case what I'm
going to claim is that the reasonable
way to think of the whole is it's that
our can range all the way from 0 to
infinity now you may not like this but
these are maybe my 1st and 3rd favorite
number my second favorite number being 1
so so so infinity is a really useful
concept of course it's nonsense in a
context of the darts because if you
think of the basement wall where you
know that the kid might miss the target
he'd probably hit the wall he's probably
not going to hit one of the walls to the
right and anyway he's certainly right
and he's not going to hit over there so
there's there's there's something
artificial about sending the possibility
of hits
all the way out to infinity on the other
hand the shape of this curve is such
that the the real tail ends here because
of this exponential decrease are tiny
and that's negligible and the point is
that actually the value if you go all
the way to infinity is the easiest value
to calculate so by doing this I'm
idealizing the problem but I'm actually
making the numbers come out much more
cleanly and this is just always done in
mathematics that's what we did when we
went from differences to differentials
to differentiation and infinitesimally
so so we like that because it makes
things easier not because it makes
things harder alright so we're just
going to pretend the whole is from zero
to infinity
and now let's just see what it is it's C
pi times the starting place is each of
the minus zero squared that's our one
right this is the the role that our one
plays is this and the our two is this
value minus e to the minus infinity
squared which is that negligibly small
number zero all right so this is just C
pi because this number is one and this
other number is zero this is just one
minus zero in the parenthesis there and
now I can tell you from these two
numbers what the probability is the
probability that we landed on the target
in a radius between r1 and r2 so that's
this annulus here is the ratio of the
part to the hole which in this case just
cancels the C pie so it's e to the minus
R 1 squared minus e to the minus r2
squared there's the the formula for the
probability so the C cancelled and the
pie cancelled it's all gone
now again let me just emphasize the way
this formula is supposed to work the
probability of the total probability of
every possibility here is supposed to be
set up to be 1 this is some fraction of
one if you like it's a percent what's
some kind yes this one is giving the so
the question is doesn't this just give
the probability of the ring this gives
you the probability of the ring but this
is a very very wide ring this is a ring
starting with zero nothing on the inside
and then going all the way out so if
that's everything so this corresponds to
everything this corresponds to a ring
okay all right so now let's see where do
I want to go from here so in order to
make progress here I still have to give
you one more piece of information and
this is again supposed to be realistic
you know when I was three years old and
my brother's friend Ralph was 7 I
watched him throwing darts a lot and I
would say that for Ralph so so for Ralph
at age 7 anyway later on he got a little
better at it but at Ralph's at age 7 the
probability that he hit the target was
about 1/2 all right so he hit the target
about half the time and the other times
you know it there was cement on the
walls in the basement it wasn't that bad
just bounced off that also meant that
the points got a little blunt or as time
went on so it was a little less
dangerous when they hit you all right so
now so here's the here's the the extra
assumption that I want to make so a is
going to be the radius of the target
now the other realistic assumption that
I want to make is where this little kid
would be standing and now here I want to
get very specific and just do the
computation in one case we're going to
imagine the target is is here and the
kid is standing say between so we'll
just do a section of this this is
between 3 o'clock and 5 o'clock there's
there there's more of him but it's but
it's lower down and maybe negligible
here so this section is the part of the
chunk that we want to to see about and
this is a and then this distance here is
2 a and then the the longest distance
here is 3 a so so the longest distance
is 3 a so in other words what I'm saying
is that the probability if you're
standing too close the chance
Ralph hits younger brother is about 1/6
right because because 2 over 12 is equal
to 6 sorry is equal to 1/6 1/6 of the
probability that we're between a and 3a
all right that's the number that we're
we're looking for another question
the two over 12 came from the fact that
we assumed so we made a very very bold
assumption here we assumed that this
human being who is actually standing
right the floor is about down here right
maybe he wasn't that tall but anyway so
he's really a little bigger than this
that the part of him that was close to
the target covered about this section
here between radius 2a and 3a as you'll
see actually from the from the
computation because the likelihood drops
off pretty quickly whatever of him with
standing outside there wouldn't have
mattered anyway so we're just worried
about the part that's closest to the
target here why is it out of 12 because
I made it a clock and I made it from 3
o'clock to 5 o'clock so it's two of the
twelve hours of a of a clock all right
it's just a way of me making a section
that you can visibly see all right ok so
now so here's the here's what we're
trying to calculate and in order to
figure this out I need one more item
here so maybe I'll leave myself a little
bit of room I have to figure out
something about what our information
gave us which is that the probability
sorry this this probability was 1/2 so
let's remember what this is this is
going to be e to the minus 0 squared
minus e to the minus a squared that's
what this probability is and that's
equal to 1/2 all right so that means
that 1 minus e to the minus a squared is
equal to 1/2 which means that e to the
minus a squared is 1/2
I'm not going to calculate AI this is
the part about the information about a
that I want to use so that's that's what
I'll use and now I'm going to calculate
this other probability here so the
probability right up there is is this
and that's going to be the same as e to
the -2 a the quantity squared minus e to
the minus 3a the quantity squared that's
the what we calculated and now I want to
use some of the arithmetic of exponents
this is e to the minus a squared the
quantity to the fourth power right
because it's really 2 a squared is 4 the
quantity is 4 a squared and then I bring
that exponent out minus e to the minus a
squared to the 9th power that's 3
squared and so this comes out to be 1/2
to the fourth power minus 1/2 to the 9th
power which is approximately 1/16
this is negligible this is this part
here and this is actually why these
tails is you go out to infinity don't
really matter that much now this is a
much smaller number so the probability
of the whole band is 1/16 and now I can
answer the question up here this is
approximately 1/6 times 1/16 which is
about 1/100 or about 1% so if I stood
there for a hundred attempts then my
chances of getting hit were pretty high
all right well that's that's the that's
the computation all right
okay that's that's a typical example of
a problem
in probability and let me just make one
more connection with what we did before
this is connected to weighted averages
or integrals over weights but the weight
that's involved in this problem was W of
R is equal to so let's just look at what
what happened in all those integrals
what happened in all the integrals was
we had this factor here 2 pi R and if I
include this see it was really yeah it
was really 2 pi C R e to the minus R
squared this was the weight that we were
using the relative importance of things
now this is not the same as the e to the
minus R squared that we started out with
because this is the one dimensional
histogram and that has to do with the
method of shells that gave us that extra
factor of R here so that also connects
with the question at the beginning which
had to do with this paradox that it
looks like these places in the middle
are the most likely but that's the plot
of e to the minus R squared if you
actually look at this plot here you see
that as R goes to 0 it's going to 0 this
is a different graph here and actually
it so this is what's happening really in
terms of how likely it is that you'll
get within a certain distance of the
center of the target
okay again it's not the area under that
curve that we're doing it's that that
volume of revolution okay all right
we're gonna change subjects now okay one
more question
yes that's supposed to be the graph of
WFR so the question is wouldn't the
importance of the center be greatest
it's a question of which variable you're
using according according to pure radius
it's it's not it turns out that there's
some bands and radius which are more
important more likely for hits than
others it really has to do with the fact
that the center the core of the target
is really tiny and so it's harder to hit
where as a whole band around the outside
has a lot more area there are many many
ways to hit that band so it's a larger
area so there's a competition there
between those two things all right so
we're gonna move on and I want to talk
now about a different kind of weighted
average these weighted averages are
going to be much simpler and they come
up in what's called numerical
integration
there are many many methods of
integrating numerically and they're
important because many many integrals
don't have formulas and so you have to
compute them with it with a with a
calculator or a machine so these are the
so now the first type that we we've
already done a Riemann sums they turn
out to be incredibly inefficient they're
lousy the next rule that I'm going to
describe is a little improvement it's
called the trapezoidal rule and this one
is much more reasonable than the Riemann
sum unfortunately it's actually also
pretty lousy there's another rule which
is just a slightly trickier rule and
it's actually amazing that it exists and
it's called Simpsons rule and this one
is actually pretty good
no but it's it's it's clever so let's
get started with these and the way I'll
get started is by reminding you what the
Riemann sum is so this is a good review
because you need to know all three of
these and you're gonna want to see them
all laid out in parallel ok so here's
this set up ok so here we go we have our
graph we have our function it starts out
at a it ends up at B maybe goes on but
we're only paying attention to this
interval this is the function y is equal
to f of X and we split it up when we do
Riemann sums so this is one this is
Riemann sums we start out with a which
is a point we call x0 and then we go a
certain distance we go all the way over
to B and we subdivide this thing with
these Delta X's
which are the step sizes all right so we
have these little steps of size Delta X
corresponding to these X values we have
Y values y 0 is f of X 0 that's the
point above a then y 1 is f of X 1
that's the point above X 1 and so forth
all the way up to Y n which is f of X in
order to figure out the area you really
need to know something about the
function you need to be able to evaluate
it so that's what we've done we've
evaluated here at n plus 1 points
enumerated 0 through through n and those
are the numbers out of which we're going
to get all of our approximations to the
integral so somehow we want to average
these numbers so here's our goal our
goal is to average or add I'm using
average very loosely here but I'm gonna
I'm gonna say add up these numbers to
get get an approximation to average or
add the Y's to get an approximation to
the integral which we know is the area
under the curve so here's what the
Riemann sum is it's the following thing
you take y0 + y1 + up to y + -1 and you
multiply by Delta X that's it now this
one is the one with left endpoints so
the left-hand sum there's also a right
one which is if you start at the
right-hand ends and that will go from y1
2yn okay so this one is the right hand
right Riemann sum all right those are
the two that we did before now I'm going
to describe to you the next two they
have a similar pattern to them and the
one with trapezoids requires a picture
here's a shape and here's a bunch of
values and we're trying to estimate the
size of these chunks and now instead of
doing something stupid which is to draw
horizontal lines in rectangles we're
going to do something slightly more
clever which is to draw straight lines
that are diagonal you see that many of
them actually coincide pretty closely
with what I drew there although if
they're curved eight they miss by a
little bit all right so this is called
the trapezoidal rule because if you pick
one of these shapes say this is y 2 and
this is y 3 if you pick one of these
shapes this height here is y 2 and this
height is y 3 and this base is Delta X
this is a trapezoid all right so this
being a trapezoid I can figure out the
its area and what do I get I get the
base times the average height if you
think about it if you work out what
happens when you when you do something
with a straight line on top like that
you'll get this average all right so
this is the average height
of the trapezoid and now I want to add
up I want to add them all up to get my
formula for the trapezoidal rule so what
do I do
I have Delta x times the first one which
is y 0 plus y 1 over 2 that's the first
trapezoid the next one is y 1 plus y 2
over 2 and this keeps on going and at
the end I have Y n minus 2 plus y and
minus 1 over 2 and then last of all I
have Y n minus 1 plus y n over 2 all
right that's a very long formula here
we're going to simplify it quite a bit
in just a second
what's this equal to well notice that I
get y 0 over 2 to start out with and now
Y 1 got mentioned twice each time with a
factor of 1/2 so we get a whole y1 in
here and the same thing is going to be
true of all the middle terms you're
going to get Y 2 and all the way up to Y
n minus 1 but then the last one is
unmatched yn is only 1/2 only counts 1/2
so here is what's known as the
trapezoidal rule now I'd like to compare
it for you to the Riemann sums which are
sitting just to the left here here's the
left one and here's the right one if you
take the average of the left and the
right that is 1/2 of this plus 1/2 of
that there's an overlap the y1 through
yn things are listed in both but
why 0 only gets counted a half and the
yn only gets counted a half so what this
is is this is the symmetric compromise
between the two Riemann sums this is
actually equal to the left Riemann sum a
plus the right Riemann sum divided by
two
it's the average of them
now this would be great and it does look
like it's a closer but actually it's
it's not as impressive as it looks if
you actually do it in practice it's it's
not very efficient although it's way
better than a Riemann sum it's still not
good enough so now I need to describe to
you the the the fancier rule which is
known as Simpsons rule and so this is if
you like three method three the idea is
again to divide things into chunks but
now it always needs and to be even in
other words we're going to deal not with
just one box we're going to deal with
pairs of boxes here's Delta X and here's
Delta X again and we're going to study
the area of this of this piece here so
let me focus just on that part
well let's reproduce it over here
and here's the Delta X here's Delta X
and of course their various Heights this
starts out at y 0 this is y 2 and this
middle segment is y 1 all right now the
the approximating curve that we're going
to use is is a parabola that is we're
going to fit a parabola through these
three points and then we're going to use
that as the approximating area now it
doesn't look like this looks like it
misses but actually most functions
mostly wiggle either one way or the
other they don't switch they don't have
inflection points so this is a lousy at
this scale but when we get to a smaller
scale this becomes really fantastic as a
as an approximation now I need to tell
you what the arithmetic is and in order
to save time it's on your problem set
what the actual formula is but I'm going
to tell you how to think about it I want
to you to think about it as follows so
the area under the parabola is going to
be a base times some kind of average
height and the base here you can already
see it's 2 Delta X the base is 2 Delta X
now the average height is weird you have
to work out what it is for a parabola
depending on those three numbers y0 y1
and y2 and it turns out to be the
following formula it has to be an
average but it's an interesting weighted
average so this was the punchline if you
like is that there are such things as
interesting way to average this one's
very simple just involves three numbers
but it's still interesting it's the
following it turns out to be wise
plus 4 y 1 plus y 2 divided by 6 Y
divided by 6 so it's supposed to be an
average all right so the total is 1 plus
4 plus 1 of these things and 6 is in the
denominator all right so it emphasizes
the middle more than the sides and
that's what happens with a parabola all
right so this is a computation which is
on your homework and now we can put this
together for the full Simpsons rule
formula which I'll put up over here we
have here 2 Delta X and we divide by 6
and then we have y 0 plus 4 y 1 plus y 2
divided by 6 plus that's the first chunk
now the second chunk maybe I'll just put
it in here starts this is this is X 2
this is X 0 and it goes all the way to X
4 so the next 2 X 3 X 4 so the next one
involves the indices 2 3 & 4 so this is
y 2 plus 4 y 3 plus y 4 divided by 600
no I think I'll get rid of these sixes I
have too many sixes all right let's get
rid of them here let's take them out put
them out here all right
thank you all the way to the end which
is yn minus 2 plus 2 yn minus 1 sorry
plus 4 y n minus 1 plus y n I was about
to divide by 6 but you saved me all
right so here are all the chunks now
what does this pattern come out to be
this comes out to be the following this
is one for one added two one for one
additive
one-for-one you add them up you get one
four and then there it's a repeat so you
got a 2 and a 4 and a 2 and a 4 and a 1
so the pattern is that it starts out
with ones on the far ends and then fours
next in and then it alternates twos and
fours in between alright so the full
pattern of Simpsons rule is Delta X
divided by 3 I have now succeeded in
canceling this 2 with the 6 and getting
out that factor of 2 and then here I
have y 0 plus 4 y 1 plus 2 y 2 plus 4 y
3 plus it keeps on going and keeps on
going and keeps on going and in the end
it's 2 y n minus 2 plus 4 y n minus 1
plus y n so again 1 and a 4 to start 1
and a 4 and a 1 to end and then
alternating twos and fours in the middle
and this weird weighted average is way
better as I will show you next time